hello everybody welcome to part 5 of
let's play amnesia the Dark Descent now
if you all remember we got left off just
after the water park so far I've
discovered that the water part is
infamous for being scary but I wasn't
scared as you guys saw totally totally
not scared totally keeping it together
and whatnot
to go back and see how it was scared at
all yeah anyway gone up the stairs now
to a new mats
and
there we go all right
doing tricks on me that's creepy yeah
Wow
I can touch it I can touch it
ah yeah well beans
always still here splashing oh it's a
weird why is it wet why am i wet
okay storage sounds good to me
wait how can he think it and scream it
at the top of his lungs at the same time
boy it's dark
oh god it's a pitch-black
whoa
Oh is there
hey buddy no
yeah I didn't think so
some creepy music scare me can't scare
me that's not good it won't budge okay
good that's great
can't go that way and AHA instrumental
ah I know come true come on out ha ha
who's there no one that's what I thought
give me a tinderbox explosives Oh
two large vats ok mix the liquids sounds
good
where the liquids dark fats
loser Oh blood tinderbox
ah just bucks ah
Dhanam alright tinderbox let's go not
finding anything story related by useful
items ten debacle on oh wait ah alright
what do I do
ah Oh genius genius what what other
parts would you need the drill part and
a drill part secondary Dakotas and area
Oh primary primary youth
uh-huh uh-huh real-part go drill
something good ha give me come here I'll
stop whining you big baby
aha yeah I'm guessing I drill this
primary boom
you like blow up this whole room wild
wild why did I need to drill it when
there's a valve right there
oh ha ha oh that's why ok game logic
boom has the stuff explosive shouldn't
just be carrying it them seems like a
bad idea
oh [ __ ] alright now we're making
progress
oh it's on
chuck it ha
ah ah
like a timer zone
I was
bone
ah smart smart smart smart still
bucks
got a pickup like 520 bucks for
everything uh-oh
barrels hi
you know I'm coming to save you lady I
can still hear you crying therefore you
must be alive not some monster trying to
trick me
well who's there
now who's there [ __ ] ha ha ha oh I
didn't expect there to be
ah okay huh - we I could go out there
and fight away okay oh that's lovely
go out there fight it but I don't feel
like it I don't want to scare any of you
guys might be scared trying to play that
thing but I won't subject you to that
I'll just hide it out goes away
sanity okay
nice camera plenty of food play a food
Oh
ah no no leave me alone
whoa whoa oh why did he come in here
because i those barrels can he hear
things
ah go away
still
Oh
oh why is he still there
Oh doing just different run paths or
something oh god I don't want it I don't
want to go look over there okay
oh boy
okay all right oh okay
ah no no come here
don't do it don't do it no no no no no
no okay all right
last piece of look is right behind him
Oh God Oh God I'll go don't look it no
no no no Hugh who don't you forget
however okay MA okay all right I'm cool
calm got it all together
good luck thank you thank you
oh he's gonna kill me oh why did I open
that room hmm okay all right good laughs
oh don't be nervous
oh don't be murdering oh that was a
murder I just wished it witnessed a
murder okay all right uh-huh machine
parts that sounds exciting
whoa aah
definitely not rose petals that was
blood blood
ow up job duh
fire okay all right that was my fault
officers being stupid
don't want that monster but raping me
for phase amplitude rah
Trinity spoon one rod in the inner
studies room okay all right fine
elevator ha ha all right
stop that Oh
anybody dare No
yeah I didn't think so back off yeah I'm
the man yet don't even know
actually I'm gonna pause it here and
then start right back up again it's got
a video thing you know you do alright
catch you in part 6 and thanks for
watching